[Music]
welcome to you life you lose your Jim's
favorite show yes yes we don't really
the clapping on this one that's let's
see how the other video did Oh another
company claimed the whole video because
of a two second clip oh that's great
that's fine because I especially I don't
like my earning money but I especially
like when my money goes to someone else
that's how I like it
and in that honor and in that fashion we
are going to have our video that's right
it's our video now Sukup edition that's
right
in honor of this new YouTube your video
is my YouTube my revenue is your revenue
please do enjoy and have a good time why
earn money when other people can have
that money yes more people should have
more money that's right people who work
for money should not have money which
are you stupid it's our money should we
start the video or should I just keep
ranting about comedy
[Laughter]
[Music]
taking all the technology 2006 six
[Applause]
[Music]
wait is there more other it's great
why is he walking like that
[Music]
you can tell her immediately that Russia
is at least 20 years ahead of America
finally this is some hidden footage that
has not yet been released
[Music]
we see here who can do it faster damn it
damage we're so close we have not
perfected it yet but we are getting
there it's all in the details don't
worry it's just a legality issue
oh my guys seen this one you can't just
sleep on the snow Russia please what are
you doing it's over the lake he's
sleeping I read what Russian walrus do
you don't see those every day what a
sight
what a culture who said white people
don't have culture my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what is the average IQ in Russia it must
be at least over 70 sorry I don't mean
to generalize of course we're just
having fun here guys we're just having a
little laugh give me and I show how who
is this dude is this like Russian he
thinks he back my bottle is through my
window just below what is the plane
doing no poor cat
please I have only a pan to everyone
have she just brought on that everyone
has an axe right right of course
oh no okay
timber
Oh No I don't know if I can laugh or not
I don't know if the cat is okay or not
okay what is this job
rushon minecraft channel yeah that's
that's cool man
that's cool that's a really cool
building by the way give Bunyan's this
hook up hook man
yes the famous battle man versus giant
bulldozer thing
[Music]
oh he's on fire he's on fire on fire
this is what happens when you don't have
internet okay
[Music]
the Russian military fearless says any
summer they're strong and his factors
[Music]
this is actually about the army this is
the Special Forces
I can't this is so dumb they don't thing
[Music]
I think this is probably one of my
favorite you left you'd lose probably we
are not using half of these but I had a
great time at they'll at least most
likely this movie monetize properly but
hey at least we had fun everybody leave
a like if you Scott that Lee would like
it fewer and remember to laugh you lose
if you laugh you lose and if you lose
your laugh and so forth thank you for
watching I am your host
[Applause]
[Music]